o tema dessa palestra começou há
bastante tempo atrás quando um amigo meu
me disse essa frase fatídica miguel pelo
seu facebook
você parece ser bem sucedido pra caramba
e eu parei pensei puxa vida isso não
está certo é porque essa é a métrica né
e num possível que essa é o jeito de
explicar e de dizer né
uma outra coisa que acontece é que até
foi uma coisa que a gente
alguns amigos inventaram essa hashtag
que o glamour empreendedor é porque as
pessoas vieram de fora e acham que
empreender é uma coisa que tem um
glamour não é que tem se faz uma coisa
de bacanas e participa de eventos e
evair lugares legais mas tem o bastidor
tenho o que você tem que fazer o seu
trabalho que ninguém vê quantas horas
você trabalha com as dificuldades para
os desafios ea gente criou essa nessa
hashtag para brincar com isso porque
toda hora que a gente estava fazendo
alguma coisa
às 3 horas da manhã a gente tava ea
gente está trabalhando a gente falava
sobre isso coloca uma tag glamour
empreendedor porque é esse é o glamour
não é eu tô aqui num palco incrível é
que eu poderia dizer um amigo eu poderia
dizer tipo olha o glamour empreendedor
né tá aí no palco mas ele fala dos
bastidores
eu vim falar das entranhas e você
empreender essa é a minha foto 12 anos
de idade
você já se sentiu sozinho diferente e
deslocado estranho quando tinha dois
anos
a minha família descobriu que tinha uma
espécie de câncer no olho e as toma e o
jeito de lidar com isso quando tinha
dois anos atrás ou seja muitos anos
atrás era tirar o olho você tem um olho
de vidro meu olho esquerdo onde vidro
ele não enxerga essa história isso
aconteceu comigo
me marcou de diversas formas de uma m
marcou inclusive de formas negativas e
positivas
por exemplo eu tinha uma dificuldade
incrível em achar em acreditar que eu
consegui arrumar uma namorada e que
estava no meio da faculdade eu
continuava com esse bloqueio e eu
resolvi falar não para aí eu tenho que
superar isso eu vou superar isso aí
inventei uma cantada para superar isso
chegava num bar tomava dois ou três
cervejas chegava por uma menina tirava o
olho esquerdo de vidro falava todo de
olho em você
obviamente óbvia
obviamente essa cantada nunca funcionou
nunca né a conversão foi zero no meu
histórico de uso dela mas foi uma
cantada que serviu para superar esse
estágio
e quando eu olho pra essa pressa
história que me marcou muito me marca
até hoje diversas formas
eu percebo que tem muita coisa na minha
vida inclusive na minha empresa na minha
trajetória empreendedora que tem a ver
com isso
eu comecei a contar essa história
abertamente para pessoas que nem conheço
como aqui né num palco tem menos de dois
anos quando comecei a contar isso foi
libertador
eu descobri uma série de outras coisas
que os medos que eu tinha é são muito
parecidos eles são menos grandes dentro
de mim e são medos também infundadas ou
menos que eu construir
eu aprendi muita coisa com essa história
do olho de vidro
eu aprendi que eu me sentia estranho que
eu me sentia diferente que me sentia
deslocado mas por causa disso eu aprendi
a ser amigo até empatia assim agregador
então as pessoas no mercado falam que o
reuni as pessoas que desenvolver a
habilidade de agregar as pessoas de
criar a comunidade de conectar as
pessoas de certa de fazer ou então é de
fazer essa conexão de segundo de
relacionamento outra coisa
por eu ter de alguma forma ter ficado
perto da morte
a minha eu tô mais presente mais vivo
tem mais propostas no que eu faço porque
eu sei que a vida pode ser muito curta e
quem já de alguma forma ficou perto da
morte porque viu algum parente morreu
porque passou perto de um acidente ou
passou por um acidente está mais
presente pra isso e também talvez por
causa disso a minha vontade de fazer as
coisas é maior então tenho quando você
olha os três valores centrais meus né
eu considero que o aplica isso negócio o
empreendedorismo é comunidade é criar a
comunidade tem a ver com a história do
meu olho tenha entusiasmo alegria
energia tem a ver com a vontade tem a
ver com vivacidade tem a ver com
vontade de viver ea terceira o valor
também é de uma história é relacionado
com a minha infância quando era pequeno
eu convivia muito com uma uma pessoa que
era meu braço direito do pai que era bem
mais velho tinha cerca de 1 70 anos e
ele já falecido hoje se chamava seu
vicente e ele me conversava comigo
contava histórias pra mim e o meu
terceiro valor e crescimento e
aprendizado porque lá atrás eu gostava
muito de ficar perto de uma pessoa que
me ensinava coisas que me contava
histórias e hoje meu negócio é difundir
o conhecimento das melhores pessoas das
melhores cabeças melhor conhecimento no
meu setor levar isso pra fora do mesmo
jeito que eu escutava do seu vicente me
contando quando era criança então o que
eu tenho de aprendizado aqui é que a sua
história os seus momentos mais difíceis
e coisas que aconteceram lá atrás muitas
vezes determinam e marcão e moldam quem
você é
que negócio você vai montar e que
negócio você quer ter a empresa é o
espelho do dono e quando descobri isso
achei muito ruim porque a empresa tinha
um monte de coisas feias
eu não podia mais xingar o espelho você
muda a imagem do espelho você muda o que
está parecendo o que está projetando no
espelho e aí eu achei ruim mas achei bom
porque agora tinha como resolver já que
mudar em minhas coisas que não era fácil
era gostosinho da e ao mesmo tempo
quando você olha empresas de sucesso
empresas que duraram tem a ver com isso
porque aquilo é o dono é então ele vai
se entregar de uma forma intensa de uma
forma com é persistente uma forma
resiliente como ninguém faria porque ele
é daquele jeito não pode parecer coisa
mais imbecil do mundo mas ele vai fazer
mesmo que é errado porque só serve para
aquilo da regra dos 10 x tudo o que for
fazer você calcula quanto de trabalho
vai dar se multiplica por dez
talvez você project certo né e talvez
vai ser 100 x né e me pergunta como é
que eu sei disso né
e aí você é vai vendo que as
dificuldades também ela se moldam de uma
forma que você não esperava que você não
queria que você não pediu por isso o meu
jeito eu não pedi pra ter um problema no
olho mas essa experiência negativa me
moldou de diversas formas inclusive de
formas positivas
é isso que acontece com a gente todo
toda pedra no caminho ela pode se tornar
uma alavanca para a gente ela pode se
tornar o que vai mudar a gente que vai
fazer a gente vai fazer a gente dá o
salto e se tornar quem a gente é a nossa
melhor forma
cada pessoa tem a genialidade dentro
dela de um jeito único de um jeito
especial isso vai aparecer
à medida que você passa pela dificuldade
da sua vida
e para superar essas dificuldades de
passar por essas dificuldades têm que
preservar a sua autoconfiança e talvez a
melhor maneira de preservar a confiança
que eu conheço e que eu busco tempo todo
é ter uma rede do bem tem uma rede de
pessoas que apóiam que estimulam que
acredita em você e te ensina o que te
inspiram e isso foi resumido em uma
palavra pessoas que se importam se
importam com você se importam e uma
forma completa e integrada
procure pense agora quais são as pessoas
da sua rede do bem com as pessoas que
você gostaria que estivessem na sua rede
do bem
isso vai te dar forças principalmente
nos momentos difíceis porque se você
resolveu empreender vão ser muitos
momentos de difícil definição do que é
um negócio muitas vezes têm uma idéia
tem uma ideia vou montar um negócio
negócio coisa relativamente simples
você tem que ter um cliente que você vai
atender esse cliente tem uma dor
ele tem um problema ele tem um desafio e
você tem uma solução para esse problema
para essa dor para esse desafio e você
vai ter que de alguma forma opera isso
fazer isso acontecer
e se o negócio não está dando certo
provavelmente é nesses quatro pontos que
tem alguma coisa que não está perfeito
que não tá melhor jeito talvez você
tenha uma solução mas não tem dor não
existe dor ou se o cliente não percebe
que tem dor
e obviamente ele não vai pagar por uma
coisa que ele não vê necessidade de
resolver a gente vê isso acontecendo
isso parece tão simples tão bobo mas é
empresas pequenas e grandes cometam esse
erro
então quando eu estiver olhando o seu
negócio a negócio de alguém procura por
responder essas questões
quem é o cliente que dor que esse cara
tem que tá doendo está latejando e que
eu tenho o remédio perfeito pra é é
curar essa dor e eu vendo por 10 esse
remédio e não me custa 11 para entregar
ele custa menos que 10 porque se ele
gostar mais do que você você vende isso
não é um negócio é uma maneira de
queimar dinheiro você olha essas quatro
coisas
treine a sua visão de negócios como
assim milhão eu sou uma pessoa viciada e
andar pelos lugares pelos negócios e
ficar olhando como aquele negócio
funciona o que a pessoa está comprando
ali que dor que está resolvendo e eu
fico na minha cabeça de maluco
utilizando isso ele podia fazer
diferente a essa é a lanchonete
cafeteria essa padaria tem mais gente o
fluxo está funcionando então tem mais
tem mais gente ea velocidade de entrega
do meu o pãozinho na boa
ao mesmo tempo eu fui no show do gongo
stoned na minha cabeça de maluco eu fico
analisando um negócio quando lá no show
rooms né e eu estou lá no show dos
rolling stones esperando e tal daqui a
pouco os caras então começa a tocar e
dezenas de milhares de pessoas ao mesmo
tempo começam a pular e logisticamente e
aí por acaso tem um tempo perdendo então
estava totalmente sóbrio e capaz e
presente e atento e perceber em todos os
detalhes e eu parei olhei assim falei
poxa vida
esses caras não vendem música esses
caras eles vendem estado mental
eles vêm de um estado mental diferente
de alegria de viver a cidade e
aqui o que o estado mental que se
encontra está entregando pra vocês é
esse tipo de coisa que eu procuro olhar
porque muitas vezes a gente acha que
está vendendo uma coisa e tal nossa
solução é uma coisa ou não a dor que a
gente está curando é uma e não é outra
ea gente o negócio tamang porque você
não entendeu qual é a dor e qual é a
solução qualquer cliente como você
melhor entrega essa dor né
cuidado também com a linguagem porque a
linguagem diz como você pensa como você
conversa com os outros e com você mesmo
né
tem gente que pensa empresas grandes são
mais um e se você quer fazer que a sua
empresa seja um grande sucesso vai ficar
grande um dia e sucesso que empresa
grande amar você vai se boicotará que
ela não vende grande porque você não
conhece uma pessoa má
ou então você pensa que dinheiro é mal o
dinheiro ruim então inconscientemente
você vai dar um jeito de não ter muito
dinheiro porque isso faz mal como isso
vai causar muito impacto se você tem uma
empresa que não é grande ou se você
dinheiro é um oxigênio é o caso à
gasolina que pode colocar no seu carro
para onde você quer você escolhe mas sem
gasolina você não vai para lugar nenhum
ou então quando eu tive um ano terrível
em que eu tive muitos prejuízos na minha
empresa eu achei que ia quebrar
eu tinha ataques de hackers e um dos
melhores amigos tinha pego um grande
empréstimo comigo e não ia pagar
tinha um monte de coisa acontecendo na
minha vida aqui é tudo negativo e eu
comecei a falar isso pra mim mesmo falar
isso pra outros amigos credenciando-se
não foi terrível
depois e no pr foi perdido e aí é eu
comecei a olhar de uma outra forma
será que empresas grandes são mais ou
empresas mais são mais interessa é
pequeno se é grande
dinheiro é ruim o dinheiro é poder e
liberdade porque o acho que mais
valoriza a autonomia e liberdade de
fazer o que eu quiser e com a minha
empresa ela é lucrativa eu posso
escolher ninguém pode mandar o que tem
que fazer
eu quero seguir aquele caminho quero
atender esse cliente eu quero fazer de
tal e tal forma que eu acredito está
mais alinhado com meu propósito porque
eu tenho um fluxo de caixa
simples assim ou então ao invés de dizer
que eu perdi esse ano eu comecei a dizer
que eu aprendi esse ano porque eu não
posso ter desperdiçado o ano inteiro
tendo s aulas que me custaram caríssimo
foram as aulas mais caras que eu já
paguei a minha vida foram essas aulas
nem as aulas que você está tudo errado o
seu negócio está quase morrendo é esse
foi um grande aprendizado
mas eu demorei estava em outubro para um
amigo meu falou assim miguel uma pessoa
que também a rede do bem falar miguel
você não perder esse ano você aprendeu
este ano
faça uma lista de todas as coisas que
aprendeu e assim eu com ele na frente
dele no mesmo momento falava poxa vida
que você a favela está na minha cabeça
todas as coisas e teve inúmeros
aprendizados muito valiosos e do mês
depois definir um negócio pra você e
você olhar a quem é o cliente qualquer
dor qualquer solução e como você opera a
entrega dessa solução
eu acredito que um negócio de sucesso
nos dias de hoje ele tem que juntar duas
coisas que não dá pra entender direito é
que parecem não misturar parece água e
óleo essas duas coisas é a alma do
propósito você tem um propósito cada vez
propostas e mais importante de atrair os
melhores pessoas para trabalhar com você
e você tem os melhores clientes de você
vender uma coisa que faz sentido para as
pessoas ao mesmo tempo que você precisa
da mecânica da técnica você preciso ter
alguma coisa que melhora a vida das
pessoas é uma obrigação moral sua fica
muito bom em marketing e vendas e
operações para que isso não atrapalhe
você ajudar mais pessoas ainda é uma
obrigação sua
se você não tem um produto que ajuda
realmente os outros
trate de mudar esse produto trata de
achar alguém que você quer realmente
servir por que empreender é servir à
secura a dor de alguém que você escolheu
só que você tem a obrigação de fazer
isso se o negócio não está indo bem
porque você não tá vendendo está
fechando a conta
provavelmente é porque a gente não ficou
bom é ainda o suficiente em marketing
vendas e operações de outras coisas que
todo o negócio precisa do mesmo jeito
que um corpo é a sua estrutura sua saúde
física é o que vai carregar o corpo para
ele cumprir a missão da alma com a sua
missão que você quer chegar se não tiver
corpo não tiver força não é conseguir
fazer nada e por último quero
compartilhar com vocês porque prendem né
e só os meus três filhos numa foto tá
virando tradicional nossa que é
montinhos né é as últimas três fotos
antes dessa só tinham dois moleques em
cima de mim agora falta desse ano agora
tem o francisco que é o mais novo vai
completar um ano
semana que vem não vai ter quatro não é
eu acho que não vai agüentar o peso é
bom porque empreender primeiro que
empreender na minha visão é uma das
maneiras mais poderosos você deixa um
legado de você deixar uma marca de você
criar alguma coisa que você vai ter
orgulho disso
a segunda coisa tem a ver com os meus
filhos aqui que você dá o exemplo de
como você trabalha como você pensa de
como você opera e terceiro de uma forma
de juntar essas duas coisas você
empreender é a sua oportunidade de você
criar o seu mundo do jeito que você
acredita
do jeito que você valoriza com os
valores com os princípios como tudo que
você quer que tenha naquele mundo e tudo
que você não quer que não tenha você
pode escolher isso quando você monta a
sua empresa e você pode cultivar isso e
atrair mais pessoas que comprou essa
idéia esse sonho para trabalhar na
construção disso você construir de
alguma forma um do melhor
muito obrigado